muy buenas noches
es
realmente
prácticamente esto no hace puesto que ya
en semanas anteriores el embajador
americano había anunciado que
significativamente corrupto que iban a
ser señala a otras autoridades
paraguayas
la acusación
y te pongan la signa de haber sido al
líquido de su cargo en oportunidad de
ejercer la vicepresidencia de la
república a los efectos de verse
favorecido en una posibilidad de no ser
investigado
incluso el embajador habló de montos con
relación al soborno ofertado a funcionar
el público
injustamente valiéndose de una nuestra
persona muy cercana a él que es el señor
juan carlos es un abogado que también
fue fiscal en épocas en que la república
también fue vista al general adjunto
bueno y qué impacto tiene este
señalamiento sobre el gobierno paraguayo
bueno el principal impacto que se tiene
en realidad aquí en paraguay es e
impacta muy fuertemente al partido de
gobierno
nosotros estamos en un proceso cercano a
elecciones generales en próximos años 30
de abril y ambos candidatos del partido
colorado tanto del oficialismo como la
oposición interna han sido señalados por
los eeuu y eso evidentemente ha
impactado fuertemente en el partido de
gobierno y la oposición por supuesto que
conlleva una concertación para esa
futura elección se ve fuerte fortalecido
con esta situación
señor cano hasta el momento que
reacciones se han producido dentro del
país
bueno las reacciones son diversas los
partidos de izquierdas por ejemplo han
considerado una intromisión de los eeuu
en asuntos internos para uruguayos sin
embargo el partido de derecha
están en plena campaña electoral tenga
un buen ojo esto porque sostienen de que
primeramente los eeuu tienen
legitimación activa como para para
señalar a estas personas puesto que
afectan sus intereses entonces la
religión es indistinta hay gente que
efectivamente considera una intromisión
y hay otro sector que se considera bueno
ya que la justicia paraguaya no lo ha
hecho hasta hasta esta fecha entonces
esas son las transacciones que se tuvo
dentro del país